two of the games I really loved this
year which way my fourth and fifth slot
were so much until dawn which is kind of
crazy because I don't like horror games
but I found them both completely
fascinating for totally different
reasons so mote was like really
interesting amnesia experience that
wasn't so terrifying I couldn't finish
it because I couldn't finish a major it
had some really fascinating things to
say that you'd find in like a philosophy
class in university while until dawn
really was the quintessential horror
movie game it was so much fun and way
better executed than I think any it was
expected it would be in my other
thoughts I had sort of chewier in
adventure games like tales from the
borderlands one of Telltale's newest
games which is just so funny I think
it's probably the funniest game I've
ever played it has a wonderful
sensibility and atmosphere about it
which you don't come to expect from
telltale given they've delivered such
serious and law heavy experiences before
but I guess working with the borderlands
universe let them be a bit more silly
and a bit more playful and it all worked
out really well
aside from tales from the vorlons which
was just good fun I had dreamful
chapters in my third slot which is a
game I backed on Kickstarter I will say
that now it's the third installment of
the series that started with the longest
journey which is my favorite game that
I've ever played ever so I have really
high expectations from it but it just
delivers this in comparably well rounded
out world with these fascinating
completely perfectly developed
characters that I'm just constantly
involved by I care about what they're
doing I care about the decisions that
I'm making and the decisions are
difficult to I think sometimes telltale
moves to a place where the decisions get
a little bit predictable and you don't
really need to sit there and
are about what you're doing whereas
drink'll chances forces me to sit there
and decide whether I'm gonna make one
massive choice or another over and over
again and I find that so engaging and
just to see the way the story branches
depending on what I decide to do with
the characters is is a really good
reason to keep playing and in my number
one slot I had flat four which is a game
I hate to love actually there are so
many problems with it that I actually
did say that I think calling for that
floor game of the year is a disservice
to game of the year because I think it
does so many things that I wish it did
better like the conversation system and
stuff like that but at the end of the
day I love that world I love walking
around it I love running into NPCs who
have insane horrible sometimes tragic
backstories and talking to my companions
who were all really fleshed out it is
just a really engaging game I love
building things I love being my voiced
character and it's just the
quintessential RPG experience I was
looking for this year
[Music]